you've
uh you mentioned you lost your
father-in-law last week
uh do you think about mortality do you
think about
your own mortality are you afraid of
death i don't think about my own
mortality that much which is
probably a good thing i think death will
be
bad i wouldn't say i'm afraid of it for
me the worst thing about death is not
knowing
how the human story turns out the full
human story the full human story so if i
could right before i die
read like a wikipedia page called the
rest of human history
and have enough time just like a few
days to absorb it think about it
and know like oh well 643 years from now
that's when all the atomic weapons went
off and
here's what happened between now and
then i would feel much better dying
because that's not how it's going to be
right that's unlikely it's almost like
the
hitchhiker's guide they kind of have
what is it they have a
one or two sentence description of the
human of what goes on on earth
it's kind of interesting to think if
there's a lot of intelligent
civilizations out there
that in the big encyclopedia that
describes the universe humans will only
have one
sentence probably too true that's the
only one i can read and understand right
and it may be hard to understand the
human one past
a number of centuries yeah with ai yes
like how many years from now will
reading wikipedia be like trying to read
chaucer
which i almost can do but i actually
can't i need a translation
probably you can't do it at all yeah i
mean maybe reading will be outdated that
might be a very silly notion
maybe we're fundamentally like we think
language is fundamental to cognition but
it could be something visual or to
something totally different
exactly we'll plug in neural ink or yeah
uh but in that story that wikipedia
article do you think there'll be a
section on
uh the meaning of it
i hope not because that section we could
write now and it's just not going to be
very good
right what would you put in the section
on the meaning of uh
human existence i don't know links to a
lot of other sections
i don't think there are general
statements about the meaning of life
that have that much meaning
i think if you study different cultures
the arts travel mathematics like
whatever your thing is
yeah you'll get a lot about the meaning
of life so like it's there in wikipedia
in some bigger sense
but i don't want to read the page on the
meaning i bet they have such a page in
fact
the fact that i've never visited it none
of my friends oh here tyler here's the
page on the meaning of life i know
you've been wondering about this you got
to read this one
no one's ever done that to you have they
it probably has well
actually gone to that page it does in
fact have a lot of links to other
okay uh so that that's it
uh the meaning of life is just about a
bunch of self-referential
or uh citation needed
type of statements i think there's no
better way to end it tyler's a huge
honor i'm a huge fan
um thank you so much for wasting all of
this time with me it was one of the
greatest conversations i've ever had
thank you so much
my pleasure and delighted to finally
have met you and uh that we can do this
you